[Musique]
à cause de la hausse importante des prix
dans les supermarchés ces dernières
semaines de nombreux Français peinent à
joindre les deux bouts réduit les
courses en fait parce que sinon on peut
pas s'en sortir
mettre en place un trimestre
anti-inflation avec un certain nombre de
mesures pour aider les consommateurs le
Portugal vient de son côté d'annoncer la
suppression de la TVA sur les biens
alimentaires de première nécessité
supprimé ou baisser la TVA en France
pour faire face à une inflation qui
explose une mesure déjà réclamée par
certains il faut à tout prix en urgence
passer la TVA de 20 à 5,5 une solution
jugée peu efficace pour le ministre de
l'Économie alors le Portugal va
supprimer la TVA sur les produits
alimentaires de première nécessité
faut-il faire pareil en France
[Musique]
alors
qu'il pense qu'on devrait faire pareil
oUI NON
Ils disent non
mais en fait
il y avait Mr cocktail il y a Mister
casse-couille
non ça ne sert à rien ah pourquoi ça ne
sert à rien parce que quand on va le
faire comme on ne peut pas contrôler la
grande distribution ils vont pas
répercuter ça sur les prix donc les prix
ne vont pas baisser ça va être comme sur
la restauration et tu les oblige
on voulait les obliger
pas de conneries tu veux que je te dise
mais j'ai pas eu les patrons bah sinon
tu sais ce que tu fais mais c'est très
simple tu vas dire bah je vais vous
rajouter une taxe sinon je vais inventer
une taxe sur la grande distribution vous
allez voir vous allez faire les maladies
que toi toi toi tu as pas de couilles
arrête
c'est eux qui décide de tout illusoire
c'est pas eux qui décident de tout moi
je te dis parce que forcément parce
qu'il y a pas de fermeté voilà un
président ou un gouvernement qui
écoutez-moi bien on va mettre la TV mais
si vous faites pas baisser les prix
sur la grande distribution je peux te
dire tu vas voir si ils vont pas baisser
l'esprit maintenant vous avez vu pour le
panier
si tu enlèves la TVA lui il vend
toujours son produit sauf qu'il ne paye
pas une TVA à l'état c'est toi qui
permet de lui dire ouais mais non les
mecs en magasin ils vont mettre les
produits
ils vont pas monter le lit solaire à 7
€, ils vont mais ils vont laisser le
même prix
d'enlever la tête on peut avoir une
mesure comme ça et que les mecs derrière
ils sont obligés d'enlever la
conversation ça n'avait pas fonctionné
par exemple c'est les patrons
Gilles le fait qu'on ne soit unanimement
tous contre toi ça te met pas la puce
[Applaudissements]
est une taxe inégalitaire c'est à dire
que ça touche évidemment parce que comme
tout le monde ça touche tout le monde à
la même enseigne énormément d'argent ou
très peu d'argent tu es taxé de la même
façon donc tu es d'accord donc il faut
bien jouer sur la TVA oui mais pour
aider les plus démunis la TVA qui
rapporte énormément en France à l'état
ça permet notamment de payer toutes les
prestations sociales
non au Portugal ils ont réussi à baisser
leur déficit budgétaire aussi on en est
pas là il paye moins de 5000 les pays
comme ça le Portugal et l'Espagne et ils
arrivent dans l'espace la fiscalité très
simple non non c'est la France le plus
haut il y a pas non non non non non non
je peux te dire la vérité je connais
bien en espagnol
en Espagne est plus cher qu'en France je
connais je te dis je te dis la vérité je
connais même le sujet la fiscalité
espagnol est au-dessus de la fiscalité
je te dis que c'est faux et je te dis
que on a droit d'accord
le travail coûte plus cher en france
l'impôt sur le revenu et le plus on est
le pays le plus imposable au monde je te
dis que c'est pas au niveau des au
niveau des tranches c'est plus important
que la France lui peut-être voilà le
travail c'est une très bonne idée mais
c'est vrai que nous en France on
manifeste pour tout et par exemple la
retraite au Portugal elle est à 66 ans
et 4 mois en Espagne elle a 67 ans donc
ça c'est un coup aussi donc on peut pas
avoir le panier avec l'inflation à zéro
on peut pas avoir la retraite à 64 ans
on peut pas avoir mais non on peut pas
tout avoir en fait mais 67 ans en
Espagne avec 38 ans d'annuité au lieu de
voilà et les cotisations ne sont pas les
mêmes ici vous regardez si vous
commencez à comparer avec les autres
pays il faut tout comparer c'est dans
l'ensemble absolument et d'habitude on
se compare uniquement pour les trucs
comme les retraites quand quand ça va
dans le sens que ça les arrange là il
faut absolument faire comme le Portugal
pourquoi on est dernier de la classe
partout voilà non mais sans déconner et
pourtant on prend l'exemple quand ça va
pas on par exemple sur les autres pays
quand on nous dit regardez ce qui s'est
passé au Portugal regardez ce qui s'est
passé en Espagne regardez ce qui s'est
passé en Allemagne bah là pourquoi on
regarde pas ce qui se passe au Portugal
et pourquoi on fait pas comme eux parce
que le covid quand ils ont commencé à
fermer ça mais au Portugal ils ont fermé
les restaurants alors on fait comme au
Portugal bah là on a qu'à faire comme au
Portugal moi sont la paix 2 € à 4 balles
bien sûr pourquoi quand le baril du
pétrole il est à 80 dollars on paye
l'essence un 30 et pourquoi 80 80
dollars on paye 2 enlever les taxes sur
l'écologie déjà et vous les suspendez le
temps qu'on sort de la garnie Kalak 800
le gars là qui a combien il est le gars
850 les gens ne sont pas autant aider au
Portugal chômage mais vous vous rendez
pas en fait vous savez pas chômeurs au
Portugal d'être malade au Portugal
franchement on a beaucoup de chance et
c'est un coup bah je dis pas que j'ai de
la chance de payer avec les gens je dis
pas que j'ai de la chance depuis
naissance à 2 euros quand le baril du
pétrole il a 80 dollars et parce qu'on
m'a mis des taxes sur l'écologie des
taxes sur ce site des taxes sur cela
remettez l'essence comme il était un 40
le temps qu'on sorte de cette [__] de
crise rebaissez l'électricité le temps
qu'on sorte de cette [__] de crise et
après on parlera des choses
mais là c'est n'importe quoi
alors pourquoi Delphine
c'est vendredi il a tout dit et très
souvent sur ces sujets là il dit tout
donc qu'est-ce que je peux dire
n'importe quoi c'est des faits
pourquoi quand le baril du pétrole il
est à 80 dollars on a vu du gasoil tu
vas payer combien j'allais à l'hôpital
en 2016 en 2016 j'allais à l'hôpital
aussi quand le bar il est à 42 heures il
est où ton problème avec l'hôpital il
faut trouver l'argent ah parce qu'on t'a
dit le poids qu'il en coûte donc nous
racontait pas n'importe quoi arrêtez de
balancer des millions partout arrêtez de
balancer des millions partout dans le
monde regardons ce qui se passe chez
nous la chance d'avoir un économiste
une fois plus Gilles veut aller à
contre-courant mais malheureusement tu
vas à chaque fois contre le désirata du
peuple je suis désolé la moitié des
économistes pense comme moi
plein plein plein et nous envoie dans le
mur les économistes
à la moitié des économies s'il te disent
que la réforme des retraites là on l'a
l'argent pour la réforme des retraites
va voir sur les sur les débats ou que
les économistes ils parlent on l'a
depuis qu'on paye la CSG CRDS depuis
tu vas finir sur Radio France
toi je te vois sur France Inter je te
vois là je te vois l'année prochaine sur
France Inter donne-nous les vraies infos
français non mais c'est vrai les
économistes
la retraite c'est un accord avec moi
en économie pour avoir une mesure de bon
sens en disant que quand tu baisses la
TVA sur des biens de première nécessité
ça va aider ceux qui ont un pouvoir
on fait une pause en tout cas de crise
on fait une pause on augmente les
dépenses et on les réglera
il est bien ton système de santé
bah oui
il est mieux qu'ailleurs
on laisse se dégrader quand même aller à
l'hôpital et ne va pas débourser
d'argent
avec l'inflation
de la TVA donc à monter donc les
recettes de l'État on peut augmenter
donc il serait juste pour les produits
de première nécessité uniquement qui
sont achetés par les gens qui sont plus
dans le besoin
économiste le gasoil à 2 € la TVA elle a
monté sur gasoil sur les pattes qu'on a
augmenté la TV elle a augmenté regarde
sur les augmente
il dit quoi l'économie sur les gruyère
le gruyère le bruit sur
vous c'est pas l'économie sur le Babybel
il dit quoi le beurre le beurre à cette
balle
il dit quoi
sur le sur le kiri il y a 8 balles c'est
la protection des plus pauvres qui va
sauter avec vous c'est ça que vous voyez
pas c'est la protection sociale c'est le
système de santé
avec toi les les plus pauvres je
t'explique là ce qu'ils ont envie c'est
de pouvoir manger et pouvoir aller faire
des courses normalement il y a toujours
à côté de la place de lui qu'on va finir
non mais tu es toujours à côté
parce qu'on fait pas plein de trucs qui
sont
là ça déchire
il y a plein de gens qui pensent comme
je dis il y a plein de gens qui pensent
que des conneries aussi genre
c'est vrai qu'il y a deux courants de
penser chez les économies qui disent
qu'il faut supprimer la TVA d'autres qui
disent que ça aura un effet dévastateur
parce que sur le court terme c'est
formidable mais qu'après
il a raison les économies et deux et
deux et deux là on est dans une maison
là on est dans une situation il faut
voir à court terme là il faut faire un
incendie très rapidement bien sûr donc
là c'est pas la peine de signal moi je
commence à en avoir le cul des mecs qui
voient à 20 30 40 ans aidez-nous déjà
maintenant après on verra tu veux que je
te dise non mais c'est vrai c'est
toujours c'est les mecs ouais mais dans
20 ans dans 30 ans il va y avoir ça
aidez-nous déjà maintenant c'est pas on
pense toujours à la fin du monde je
ferais mieux penser à la fin du mois
déjà exactement
[Applaudissements]
les penseurs avant de penser à la fin du
monde pensez d'abord à la fin du mois
vous mettez ça sur mon épita moi je veux
ça sur mon écran
je vais faire un français avec ça avec
une TVA 5 5
[Rires]
moi je dirais que pour pour certains
foyers si ils ont des produits avec du
coup une réduction de 20 % ben je pense
que tout le monde peut en bénéficier et
une bonne chose c'est une bonne chose
pour le mec fin c'est toujours bien de
manger quoi je sais que tu veux dire et
c'est vrai tu sais ce qui est marqué sur
ce t-shirt je crois que tu me l'as dit
avant ouais allez tous vous faire
[__] mais en chinois
maintenant je le fais doucement j'ai pas
envie de choquer les gens
c'est vrai mais c'est bien ou Nina
madinaté
si je vais au Japon je dis kuni
Madeleine
tu leur diras que c'est une promesse ou
une menace
selon les goûts merci merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vrai imaginez imaginez un
instant les Castaldi au gouvernement
Benjamin Castaldi et sa famille à
l'économie
aujourd'hui
des 5 ans dit non il descend il est
assigné de 250 balles et je n'ai pas les
moyens monsieur Hanouna de payer 200 €
déjà c'est pas les miens
[Rires]
allez